¿Qué pasa con ustedes?
Estamos escondidos en un búnker donde están caballos arriba, tablas en la tierra.
¿Cómo era el búnker?
Era tablas, tablas así, y arriba caballos.
Una se llamaba Stodola, ¿cómo se dice en castellano?
Donde mantienen caballos.
El establo, el establo.
Esa se llama Semblanka, Semblanka, en ruso Semblanka.
Allá seguimos.
Entonces, yo de repente enfermo.
Era en marzo.
Con 40 hubo fiebre.
Y este señor también se casó con nosotros.
Estaba yo para morir.
Entonces mi señora, llorando mucho, ¿a dónde yo te voy a enterar?
Aquí me ponen la carta.
Yo con toda la fiebre, con todo, y digo así en estas palabras.
No se preocupen, yo todavía no voy a morir.
Vamos a sobrevivir la guerra.
Todavía vamos con gente más en el mundo.
Voy a tener hijos, y nietos, y bisnietos, con esas palabras.
Hoy día de Dios.
Y yo me salvo.
Estuvo allá, y yo tenía un gran machete en el búnker,
en casa que él me quería matar, pero yo sabía que era bandido,
¿yo te entiendes?
Yo maté al ante.
¿Y qué comía esos días?
Él un beso en el día, yo parecido pan, con parecido queso, es así,
y parecido carne en la tarta.
Ya.
En mayo, dijo, miren señores, ahorita se quieren salir,
Borruso está muy cerca,
los alemanes están ahí desocupando los pueblos,
están huyendo, y pueden entrar,
matan a nosotros, me queman todas las familias,
así yo tendría a él, también tiene su heredero.
Me huyeron para la montaña, otra vez,
y pidiendo mis obreros, cada noche,
ya estaba un poquitico más, aquí un pancito, aquí papa,
en junio, mayo, junio, ya era.
¿Y dónde dormía?
¿Eh?
¿Dónde dormía?
En el bosque, aquí era, ¿dónde?
Y uno no murió, uno tomó agua de ríos, con todo malo,
y uno no murió, yo no soy mire,
y uno, no sé cómo le contar.
Era, 7 de junio.
7 de junio de esa tarde,
era ante una lluvia, una lluvia que usted no me imagina.
Bujado,
terminó la lluvia,
y salió el sol rojito, lindo,
y en los ríos, agua,
yo me quito la camisa,
me puso arriba, aquí, mire,
pequeños arbolitos que se sacan,
con la cara de río.
Y pasó a llorar.
Le pregunto a mi señora, ¿por qué te lloras?
Mañana estamos en libertad.
¿A quién nos vamos a encontrar?
Que yo sabía que todos están muertos.
Soy padre, soy hermano de Camaro.
Mi hermano con la señora hija, mataron allá.
Otro hermano me mataron acá.
Me mataron cuatro meses antes de la guerra.
¿A quién nos vamos a encontrar?
¿Cómo tú sabes decir que estamos en libertad?
No sé.
O yo hablo,
o bebé Jacoides.
¿Sabe qué es bebé Jacoides?
Bebé Jacoides, ¿sabes eso?
Mojarra, estamos en bosque,
de mañana,
y ahí yo puedo aguantar más.
Vaya tú, el mismo señor, Cossack,
que era un pan.
Ahí yo podía ir más,
cambió como una polaca, estaba muy cerquita,
en el fronón del bosque.
Fui para allá.
Dice el Cossack,
Sr. Rice, ¿usted está libre?
Está libre bien, mire.
Mi señora, agarró un pan,
y está regresando,
y dice, Adam,
Adam, estamos libres.
Entonces, uno, solo,
es enemigo de uno.
¿Usted me entiende?
Yo pensaba,
que agarraron a ellos,
entonces preguntaron,
¿a dónde estaban agentes?
Dijo, tengo a mi esposo,
yo no sabía que vivían juntos,
entonces yo, en el bosque, huyendo.
Ella grita, Adam, ¿estamos libres?
Y yo huyendo, mire.
Entonces, Adam, como tú dijiste ayer,
estamos libres.
Así es el tema.
El 8 de junio,
un día después,
los hermanos se casaron.
¿Y a dónde fueron?
44.
¿Y a dónde fueron ese día?
Bueno.
Idea, un momento,
cuando usted me hable aquí de los hermanos,
¿qué le pasó?
Cuéntenme con cada uno,
¿qué pasó?
Cada uno.
Hermano,
y mi cuñado,
con dos hijos.
¿Cómo se llaman los hermanos?
Herzl, Zvi,
que murieron.
Huyeron para el bosque,
contra los hermanos y mataron a ellos.
¿En qué año?
En el año 42.
Segundo hermano,
tercer hermano,
Einar,
huyó para un pueblo
que se llamaba Kresuvka,
y estaba escondido
en un buque, en un palacio.
Esos blancos cogieron miedo,
dejaron un aviso,
¿quién esconde a un judío?
Van a matar y quemar,
entonces
se fueron
y ya,
y digo,
en mayo 44,
llegaron los hermanos y mataron.
Y último hermano,
mataron en febrero,
2 de febrero de 1944,
cuatro meses antes de...
¿En la casa donde estaba usted?
No, donde...
estaba escondido,
adonde vinieron partizanas,
dijeron que se van,
y él dijo,
yo estoy cansado de la vida,
como yo estoy con usted.
¿Hay otro mundo?
Mejor que este mundo.
¿No hay otro mundo?
Tengo nada del mundo para mí.
No tengo más fuerza para luchar.
Después, ¿qué pasó?
¿Cómo siguió la vida?
Tuve un enemigo,
se llamaba Andrés,
él estaba junto a polacos en Rusia,
y hizo muchos militares.
Se llamaban AK.
Y él dijo,
que Rusia no hace guerra contra alemanes,
él es polaco,
y él quiere ganar contra alemanes.
¿De verdad?
Polaco yo soy general.
Estaban parados en Varsovia.
Era Praga.
AK, AK, señorita.
Praga es un río,
ahí se llama Vaisel.
En Praga, allá es Varsovia.
Seis meses estaban alemanes en Varsovia,
seis meses en Varsovia,
y seis meses en Praga, rusos.
Y él quiso ser héroe de la guerra,
mató doscientos mil polacos.
El Vaisel se puso de sangre de polacos.
¿Qué pasó con ustedes dos?
Tenía que pensar, miren,
una vida.
Me regreso para mi casa y volvaba.
Pensó,
inmediatamente me entregaron mi molino.
Yo puse una ley que no me pagó dinero,
por ejemplo que van a hacer de trigo
ochenta por ciento para,
y veinte por ciento para hacer trigo.
Yo hizo trigo
y vendió, miren, para Lubin.
¿Qué mes y qué año fue eso?
En el año cuarenta y cuatro.
¿Qué mes?
Que yo fui liberado en junio,
ya en julio, agosto,
dos meses.
Entonces yo estoy en mi molino,
y mi señora está embotada,
entran dos encaballeros,
bien vestidos,
yo estoy en mi oficina.
¿Qué haya?